[Musique]
ce mardi 12 novembre s'est déroulée la
troisième rencontre départementale sur
le tage tremplin pour l'activité des
jeunes
une matinée des chances qui a permis à
plus de 150 jeunes de trouver sur un
même site tous les partenaires et
d'obtenir les bonnes réponses pour se
lancer dans la création de leur
entreprise
tout jeune qui est intéressé par le tage
et la création d'entreprises donc
s'adresse aux à un des membres du réseau
point chance donc c'est un réseau qui
était mis en place par le département
depuis plus de 20 ans qui regroupe déjà
ils tous les acteurs en fait sont
spécialisés dans l'accompagnement et
l'aide à la création d'entreprise
bon je vous la boutique de gestion
retrouvre les chambres consulaires
initiative riz entreprendre que la
couveuse réussite et c est donc cette
demande se fait par le biais d'un des
techniciens de ce réseau pro chance qui
ensuite transmis au département pour
décision finale mise en place en 2016
par le département le tage accompagne
les réunionnais en difficulté vers une
insertion professionnelle durable grâce
à l'entrepreneuriat à la tâche comme si
le slogan en fait ça a été un tremplin
en fête démarre à jour l'activité
ça m'a permise moi en tout cas
d'investir dans des machines pouvoir
d'affaires fonctionner mon entreprise à
l'entreprise et c'est tout ce qui est
conception graphique impressionné mais
vit également l'accompagnement des
entreprises sur la gestion et le
développement des réseaux sociaux où
l'entreprise est basée sur la fibre
optique du cabba gematik et à l'âme et
et caméras de surveillance
le talent ça mettait une grande aide
pour pouvoir commencer pour pouvoir
votre capital pour acheter des matériels
pour pouvoir développer et faire les
travaux adéquats à l'issue de la matinée
débat le président du département ainsi
une convention qui lie la collectivité
l'ensemble de ses partenaires va écouter
c'est une convention qui vit le
département et ses partenaires notamment
réseau et chance parce que vous savez
que nous avons l'ambition de toujours
accompagner ces jeunes notamment celles
et ceux qui veulent créer leur propre
entreprise et donc nous avons besoin de
conforter notre réseau sur tout le
territoire de la réunion pour bien
accompagner des jeunes en rose chaque
année ce sont plus de 300 personnes qui
sont accompagnés par le débordement
depuis sa création ce dispositif a
permis de soutenir mille réunionnais
dans la
création de leur propre emploi
[Musique]